I think if we can figure out a way for
dad to get me miles brisket recipe this
all goes away
huh see how we can accomplish that put
that down that's not a toy sure is cute
you open wide moon fire here comes the
choo-choo train choo-choo hmm that good
that's me most famous brisket would you
like a secret recipe you promise not to
tell anybody
of course you're not gonna tell anybody
I start with a tablespoon of cumin and
then a cup of brown sugar and I know the
recipe what she told it to me
when February 14th to 1982 I was 23
months old it was Valentine's Day and
mom and dad went out for dinner you were
there don't you remember I got nothing
you can really remember when you're that
little uh-huh you were there too you're
still struggling with potty training I
don't think so
oh yes meanwhile I used to call you mr.
soggy pants no oh mr. soggy pant quit it
this is serious John you've got to tell
Dad that recipe but meanwhile told me it
was a secret
if you don't mom and dad get a divorce
it's your fault all right fine
good job sign your pants well I know
meemaw's brisket recipe what no you
don't yes I do and in order to bring
peace to this family I prepare to make
it public you're bluffin one tablespoon
of cumin one cup of brown sugar two
tablespoons of smoked paprika okay okay
stop no no keep going how do you know
the recipe Shelly meanwhile told to me
on Valentine's Day 1982 you were out
with dad seeing Cannonball Run at the
dollar theater that's impossible you
weren't even two years old three
tablespoons of dried mustard 1 cup of
Lone Star beer okay
okay go ahead give it to your father I
can burn it down for you that's okay I
don't want it
don't let the hug fool you
the minute she went home he made me give
him the recipe
we go maiden voyage Jim want some no
thank you I'm not hungry
[Music]